hmm so you think this has nothing to do
with you you go to your closet and you
pick up that lumpy blue sweater you're
wearing for instance because you want to
tell the world that you take yourself so
seriously that you don't even care what
you put on your back but what you don't
know is that sweater it isn't even blew
it isn't turquoise and it isn't lapis
it's actually cerulean you're all so
blithely unaware of the fact that in
2002 Oscar de la Renta did a collection
of cerulean gowns and believed it was
yes de Lorette that did a collection of
cerulean military jacket and then
cerulean shot onto the shelves of eight
different designers then it found its
way into the department stores and
eventually it tripled its way down to
the cattle corner where you know don't
think that housed some clearance bin
however that blue blue represents
millions of dollars and countless jobs
kind of comical that you believe that
you have made a decision that exempts
you from the fashion industry when in
all actuality you're wearing a sweater
that was picked out just for you by the
people in this very room from a pile of
stuff